ein fakt über dem wir auch sprechen
müssen ist dass gewalt und hass gegen
polizeibeamte immer mehr zunehmen einer
der aktuellen brandbeschleuniger
natürlich die korona maßnahmen die von
den beamten eben durchgesetzt werden
müssen ja unfassbar nach dem doppelmord
wurden im netz neben diversen
beileidsbekundungen auch unglaubliche
setzte gepostet wie zum beispiel mein
mitleid hält sich in grenzen oder zwei
polizisten weniger bei den spaziergängen
und selbst schuld wir haben mit einer
frau aus bayern gesprochen über die
ständige angst die sie als ehefrau eines
polizisten tagtäglich begleitet
also ich bin am montagmorgen aufgewacht
habe dann als erstes meine bild app
geöffnet und dann war's halt wirklich ja
man kann sagen wie so ein schlag ins
gesicht wo ich die nachricht gelesen
habe von den polizisten worden weil
einfach auch in genau derselben nacht
mein eigener ehemann seinen dienst
geleistet hat er ist eben total gerne
polizist es ist eigentlich kann man
sagen sein sein hobby er spricht in der
freizeit auch sehr viel davon geht
unglaublich gerne in die arbeit und
deswegen war das für mich unverständlich
wie man kaltblütig zwei menschen zwei
polizisten einfach so niederschießen
kann hinrichten kann kann man eigentlich
schon fast sagen
ich hab dann abends in den sozialen
medien gelesen habe einfach auch
mitbekommen wie ja wie die gesellschaft
über polizisten denkt was leute posten
dass sie dazu schreiben viele die ihre
anteilnahme ausgedrückt haben aber eben
auch viele die eine ganz andere sicht
auf die polizeibeamten haben also die
arbeiten dann 10 12 stunden durch ohne
ja wenn sie viel glück haben vielleicht
was trinken zu können aber eine essen
das teilweise überhaupt nicht zu denken
weil sie in wohnungen reihen müssen um
vielleicht einen drogenfund zu machen
weil sie auf verstorbene achten bis der
leichte schauer kommt
alles das erlebt mein mann oder weil sie
straßensperren müssen und als dank dafür
schreibt die gesellschaft oder viele
menschen teilweise bei einer
straßensperrung wird mein mann
angeschrien warum man die straße sperrt
man müsse da kurz durch frage ich mich
wo bleibt der respekt einem
polizeibeamten gegenüber oder er wird
einfach so angespuckt egal ob der einige
vielleicht ein corona erkranktes ob er
hiv hat oder was auch immer für
krankheiten man spuckt einfach fremden
menschen ins gesicht
oder anderer ton ich [ __ ] deine tochter
ich [ __ ] deine frau und danach wirklich
deine mutter und bringt danach alle um
natürlich sind das höchstwahrscheinlich
alles nur leere worte aber es nimmt
einen mit und das ist das tagtägliche
geschehen was mein mann mit machen muss
oder einfach auch ein polizeibeamter
er kommt mit schrammen platzwunden nach
hause im wird an die beine getreten er
muss sich rangeln und das alles nur weil
er jemanden entdeckt hat ein täter
überführt der einfach vielleicht zehn
mal glück hatte und einmal pech und
anstatt aufzugeben und zu sagen okay
heute habe ich verloren
wird halt auch mein mann eingeprügelt